bagdad 6 heures du matin c'est l'heure
de la tournée des poubelles pour les
enfants des rues le seul moment où
chaker a une chance de les approcher
[Musique]
elles sortent à l'aube et rentre tard le
soir il récupère de la ferraille ou des
cannettes et ils vont revendre tout ça
comme ils peuvent
jegham invite toujours les jours ils
n'ont absolument aucune notion de
l'avenir
arcane à 7 ans dont trois passes et dans
les ruelles du quartier de bataille wind
drogue prostitution et trafic d'armes
c'est un des endroits les plus dangereux
de bagdad là tu vois toutes ses ruelles
elles sont réservées aux prostituées
arcanes est un des premiers enfants que
chaker et son organisation humanitaire
ont réussi à sauver de l'enfer c'était
il ya deux ans regarde ça nous arrivait
souvent de dormir là
juste à côté des groupes électrogènes
[Musique]
une fois le propriétaire du restaurant
est venu pour nous taper on s'est pas
laissé faire on lui a pris sa bouteille
on l'a tapé avec ils voulaient nous
empêcher de dormir là mais on le lui a
bien fait payer
eux
c'est mohamed et mohsen
ne filme pas ça peut les excités et ils
sont capables de nous lancer des pierres
chaker va essayer de convaincre les deux
enfants de l'accompagner
approché je veux juste vous parlez
son organisation a ouvert un foyer
d'accueil pour enfants des rues il ya
tout juste six mois
qu'est ce qu'ils disent
il pense que ça l'a promis
cela c'est les costauds qui gagne
[Musique]
celui-là vous l'avait enlevée par là
mais non pas du tout
arcane va rejoindre chaker pour essayer
de rassurer les gamins
mais rien n'y fera
il faut parfois plusieurs mois avant que
l'éducateur ne parviennent à établir un
dialogue
tu vas pas réussi à les convaincre il me
reconnais mais ils ont eu peur de
monsieur chat car ils ont cru que
j'étais pris en otage c'est ça oui c'est
ce qu'ils ont cru
c'est devenu tellement courant en irak
ces histoires de rapts d'enfants et de
femmes
du coup les enfants signifie dès qu'un
inconnu leur parle ils pensent qu'ils
veulent et kidnappés ou les découper en
morceaux
ça m'arrive tout le temps ce genre de
situation
ils ont peur oui ils ont peur
aujourd'hui on estime à près de quinze
mille le nombre d'enfants des rues à
bagdad après deux ans d'existence la
maison de l'enfant l'organisation
humanitaire de chaker elle accueille
tout juste 25 pensionnaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quartier des grands hôtels dans le
centre de bagdad
ce matin chaker a décidé de ramener
arcanes à l'endroit où il a passé plus
de deux ans de sa vie
c'est une des étapes de sa thérapie pour
aider ses protégés à passer à autre
chose
problème la sécurité autour de l'ancien
repaire de la bande d'arcane a été
renforcée à cause de la multiplication
des attentats c'est fermé
c'est là où tu étais arcanes oui c'est
l'endroit où on dort mais hélas aussi
derrière vous
derrière aussi
oui on dormait sur des couvertures ici
on faisait du feu
là on va pas pouvoir y aller
et c'est de passer à travers les
barbelés dealers qui lie à des
journalistes qui veulent filmer nous
laisseront peut-être passé
vas-y doucement
arcane va revenir accompagné d'un garde
qui a accepté de désobéir aux ordres de
ses supérieurs et nous laisser rentrer
quelques minutes chacun lui explique la
vraie raison de notre présence
confrontée l'an fin à ses pires
cauchemars c'est là dans cet immeuble
que les plus grands au sein de sa bande
abusé de lui
tiens voilà
c'était là qu'il y avait les plus grands
canaux c'est là où il était la pièce est
mûr et non c'est ma famille qui habite
ici maintenant ma femme est dedans vous
voulez rentrer seul nom on voulait juste
que le petit sachent qu'ici tout a
changé maintenant pour vous donner une
idée il ya deux ans c'était leur repère
tout ça c'était chez eux
oui effectivement ça a bien changé
maintenant ce sont des familles qui
vivent ici arcane tu dormais ici
non je devais dormir dehors et les
autres
les plus grands étaient bien au chaud à
l'intérieur
je suis toujours avec les journalistes
français ils sont en train de partir
bien reçu
bien reçu il doit partir tout de suite
les reçus
quand je suis venu chercher arxiv les
grands monts dire cet enfant c'est notre
enfant vous permettront pas de nous
prendre en fait il exploitait
sexuellement une envoyer mendier pour
eux volée pour eux le prendre c'était
leur enlever leur gagne pain
mais je voulais quand même emmené les
grandes poursuivie avec des couteaux et
on a pu arriver jusqu'à la voiture et
s'enfuir
ce jour là ça a failli tourner très mal
ses enfants c'est tous des victimes non
non ne filmaient pas
ses enfants ce sont des victimes
c'est terrible ces bandes qui leur donne
de la drogue
du haschich
les exploite sexuellement
heureusement maintenant ils sont
protégés comme toi arcanes tués dans un
orphelinat n'est ce pas
tes parents tu les as perdu il ya
longtemps je ne sais pas c'était quand
j'étais tout petit ces gamins ce sont
des victimes de la guerre les victimes
de saddam hussein
oui
la maison de l'enfant est situé à une
vingtaine de kilomètres du centre de
bagdad
juste à côté d'une caserne militaire
c'est une ancienne ferme coopérative
abandonné par ses propriétaires à la fin
de la guerre est achetée grâce aux rares
donc chaker a réussi à collecter
[Musique]
cette attention je vous ai dit que vous
alliez vous faire mal ici les critères
d'admission sont très stricte
interdiction formelle de faire entrer
des armes ou de la drogue vient ici toi
la fouille est obligatoire pour chaque
nouvel arrivant chez moi s'en tire
souffre encore
vraiment sentir ta main
ce que cherche à care c'est à déceler
l'auteur d'une drogue qui fait des
ravages dans la rue le tannat du
dissolvant pure qui montent directement
au cerveau
c'est quoi ça
les petites balles pour mon pistolet en
plastique autre inquiétude pour
l'éducateur les armes il lui est même
parfois arrivé de confisquer de vrais
pistolets lassé d'argent
tu te faisais combien
combien tu te faisais dans la rue pas de
réponse de l'adolescent pourtant saliès
de dinars représente beaucoup d'argent
l'équivalent de plusieurs dizaines
d'euros
j'ai rien d'autre sur moi
ton rire là on me la fait pas à moi
jugé suspect par l'indicateur
l'adolescent ne sera admis qu'une seule
nuit dans le foyer faute de moyens
chaker privilégie toujours les plus
jeunes ce qu'il peut encore protégés
c'est vrai que nous ne pouvons pas nous
occuper de tout le monde mais c'est
parce que nous sommes seuls la police et
des ministères concernés ne coopère pas
avec lui comme il le devrait ça c'est la
première raison mais c'est aussi parce
que les cas que nous traitons ne sont
pas tous facile il ya des cas ingérable
et n'ont pas l'air comme ça mais
certains d'entre eux sont déjà des
criminels endurcis
une fois n'est pas coutume ce matin des
habitants du quartier ont organisé une
distribution de vêtements pour les 25
pensionnaires du foyer
quand ça arrive à tablier
c'est la fin du ramadan et à bagdad
comme dans tout le monde musulman ce
jour-là il est particulièrement
recommandé de faire oeuvre de
bienfaisance
regard monte cinto 9
tee-shirt jeans chaussettes mêmes
chaussures tout neuf chaque enfant a
droit à son propre sac de vêtements et
pour certains à un habillage
personnalisés
je vous jure que même mes enfants je les
habille pas le matin cela c'est comme
mes propres présentant un petit air de
fête qui ne va pas durer
à peine sortis du salon d'essayage les
gamins vont retrouver la dure réalité de
la vie à bagdad
ce qui se passe une explosion contre les
américains américain
en fait il s'agit d'une attaque en règle
de la caserne militaire située à
quelques mètres de là
n'y allez pas les plus petit a tiré par
les rafales de mitrailleuses sont les
premiers arrivés au portail
vous n'avez pas peur et tire non là
c'est rien
une fois quand j'étais encore dans la
rue j'ai vu une énorme explosion juste à
côté de moi
j'ai même vu quelqu'un se faire couper
les deux jambes devant mes yeux
shokohman ce jour là il y avait quatre
voitures kamikaze qui avait explosé en
même temps dans le quartier caisse à
elle dit
[Musique]
et cette fois ci a eu peur
chaker ça arrive souvent des attaques
comme celle là oui c'est à cause de la
caserne à côté de la cible des
terroristes
les locaux de la maison de l'enfant sont
assez grands pour accueillir plus d'une
centaine de pensionnaires mais si chacun
préfère refuser du monde ce n'est pas
qu'à cause de la sécurité c'est aussi
pour ne pas être débordé ils sont
seulement une dizaine de volontaires
comme lui a accepté de venir ici tous
les jours pour s'occuper des enfants
vous savez où je les ramasse et lui dans
une poubelle en fait il travaillait dans
un restaurant et il y avait une grande
poubelle dans la croix il était fou et
là dedans quand on est
bon on a assez jouer maintenant faites
votre lit allez mes chéris
c'est vous qui leur avait appris à faire
leur lit
allez vas-y puis la couverture en deux
puis là
[Musique]
chaker leur apprend en priorité la
discipline l'hygiène mais aussi à
exprimer leurs émotions autrement que
par la violence
c'est eux qui ont décoré leur chambre on
essaye de réveiller leur fibre
artistique récente roller mettre de
pression
on ne leur impose rien on leur donne des
feuilles et des crayons et ils peuvent
dessiner ce qu'ils veulent
parfois les résultats sont étonnants il
ya de très belles choses
regardez là bas un de ses dessins a été
retenu pour un concours
un collage effectué à partir de
magazines représentant des animaux
sauvages mais aussi des dessins
d'enfants qui s'amusent sous une pluie
de bombes ressemblant plus à des
papillons qu'elle les engins de mort
photo de guerre aussi ou soldat
américain côtoie des enfants des rues
occidentaux cela
la plupart des enfants dont chacun
s'occupe sont orphelins mais certains
ont dû fuir des parents qu'il est
maltraité ou encore ont été jetés dans
la rue faute de place à leurs domiciles
une fois dehors ils deviennent tous
toxicomanes et quel que soit leur âge
ils ont souvent déjà une longue histoire
d'abus sexuels derrière eux
là tu vois ces petits étaient les
esclaves de ce gars au milieu
il ya quelque chose comme 25 ans c'est
lui qui leur fournissaient le canard la
drogue mais aussi des pilules
hallucinogènes les rangs des accrocs et
ensuite il abusé d'eux sexuellement en
échange de leur dose
il commence par mendier après ils
deviennent pickpockets enfin ils font
des casses et ne vienne voleurs
professionnels
à ce stade un disposent de tellement
d'argent qu'ils peuvent finir par tuer
pour le garder devenir des assassins
un gamin s'il reste un ou deux ans dans
la rue ça devient un vrai criminel mais
aujourd'hui l'autre grand risque c'est
qu'ils peuvent être récupérées par les
terroristes qui sévissent dans le pays
tenez par exemple lui c'est ta mère
satar des terroristes l'ont attrapé et
lui ont fourni de la drogue et puis ils
lui ont donné deux bombes et lui ont
demandé d'aller faire exploser une
mosquée chiite
mais heureusement des miliciens ont
attrapé avant qu'il ne puisse commettre
l'attentât et l'ont livré à la police
il est en prison aujourd'hui
donc s'ils ne deviennent pas criminel
ils deviennent terroristes c'est ça que
je redoute le plus pour les enfants
qu'ils tombent aux mains d
[Musique]
à
ce bruit c'est le camion qui sert à
désinfecter les rues
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour tuer les cafards et les
moustiques qui pullulent à cette époque
de l'année
les enfants adorent suivent le camion au
cours de notre première visite à la
maison de l'enfant nous n'avons pas vu
une seule fille chacun nous explique
pourquoi
elle c'était une de nos pensionnaires
elle s'appelait twitch
elle est venue chez nous avec deux
autres filles elle avait dix ans à peu
près
pendant deux trois jours se sentait
vraiment bien chez nous mais très vite
on s'est aperçu que les gars ont abusé
d'elle sexuellement il imitait le
comportement des plus grands dans la rue
alors on a dû s'en séparer les envoyer
dans un autre foyer réservé aux filles
[Musique]
faire sortir les plus petits des gangs
qui tiennent bagdad en coupe réglée
c'est devenu une obsession pour chaque
ère une obsession qui le pousse chaque
jour à sortir de chez lui à l'aube pour
essayer de découvrir un nouvel indice
qui lui permettrait de retrouver la
trace de ses protégés
du temps de saddam hussein chaker était
policier au sein de la brigade
criminelle
un poste qu'il a obtenu grâce à une
licence en criminologie
ce qui la décide a consacré sa vie aux
enfants c'est un meurtre
particulièrement sordide qu'il n'a
jamais réussi à résoudre celui d'un
enfant de 4 ans
[Musique]
retour à bata win le quartier des
drogués des prostituées des assassins un
véritable coupe-gorge où personne n'ose
plus s'aventurer pas même ses anciens
collègues policiers
chaker est à la recherche de karim un
gamin aux yeux verts d'à peine cinq ans
sa bande le force à se prostituer pour
ramener de l'argent
abdeslam un habitué de la maison de
l'enfant que chaker n'arrive toujours
pas à sortir de la rue va peut-être
pouvoir leur enseigner tu revenir au
foyer
et tu viens je t'emmène au foyer laisse
moi j'y suis déjà allé quoi j'y suis
allé dans la nuit mais ils m'ont refusé
c'est normal on tient on est 100 fois et
à chaque fois tu t'es enfui au bout de
quelques heures pas de trace de karim
mais vu le nombre de tubes de colle qui
gist au pied de l'escalier l'éducateur
n'aurait rien pu tirer de l'adolescent
direction le parking du quartier
[Musique]
en réalité en terrain vague entouré de
quatre murs qui sert de repaire aux
gangs du petit karim
[Musique]
leur but en plusieurs sacs remplis de
canettes
et un gardien pour éviter les mauvaises
surprises
karim est bien là tous ces couvertures
coller à un des plus grands de la bande
pas question d'éveiller les soupçons
chaker fait mine d'ignorer le petit
karim et parle d'abord à l'adolescent
pourquoi tu es dans la rue
parce que je ramasse des canettes mais
aussi en masse des canettes avec toi oui
mais toi karim pourquoi tu dors dans la
rue car hypnos pas répondre il attend
que son chef le fassent à sa place on
dort dans la rue parce que c'est la vie
c'est la vie et dans la rue vous avez
appris à vous shootez aux canards non
monsieur on ne touche pas à ça
et vous n'avez pas peur d'être dans la
rue non monsieur on n'est pas envie
d'aller dans un foyer
pour quoi faire
l'adolescent botte en touche mais chaker
veut absolument faire passer le message
à karim il sait que l'enfant est sous
influence mais il tente tout de même sa
chance
bon eh toi tu es sûr de pas vouloir
venir au foyer au foyer mais qu'est ce
que tu veux que je fasse
karim est le seul petit dans la bande
chacun va devoir amadouer ses mentors
les mettre en confiance pour pouvoir
continuer à approcher l'enfant et
espérer un jour le ramener avec le foyer
tu m'as dit que tu avais des frères et
soeurs ils sont plus âgés ctoire oui
plus âgés ils sont mariés ou invalides
en fait que tu es le seul soutien de ta
famille ouais je suis le seul sur simple
ya que toi qui aide ses frères et soeurs
mais ton père il est fonctionnaire une
sorte ni fonctionnaire à la retraite
quand tu vis comme ça
c'est la seule chose que je sais faire
mais pourquoi vous restez dans la rue où
veux tu qu'on aille là où on était avant
il ya des explosions partout là bas on
te dit ou tu viens poser des bombes avec
nous tu va trancher des gorges on a déjà
perdu trois gars de la bande comme ça
chaker c'est que les adolescents force
le petit karine à se prostituer pour eux
mais pendant plus d'une demi heure il va
les écouter patiemment plusieurs fois il
va essayer de les convaincre de laisser
partir l'ancien avec lui en vain
mais chaque air n'est pas du genre à
abandonner si facilement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour art cannes par exemple il a mis
plus de six mois avant de le sortir des
griffes de sa bande celle de l'hôtel
méridien une des plus connues de bagdad
[Applaudissements]
on avait l'habitude de cambrioler de
magasins et de se bagarrer tout le temps
un jour on est même allé dans un endroit
où on savait qu'il y avait de la drogue
du canard et du haschisch et là on nous
a tiré dessus j'étais tellement défoncé
que je me suis même pas rendu compte que
j'étais blessé je continue à rigoler
c'est après que je me suis aperçu que ma
jambe saignait je peux voir
voilà c'est là vraiment
ouais bien sûr c'est une blague
ouais et une fois il y en a un qui s'est
pris une balle dans le bras
la balle lui a traversé le bras
je me rappelle il faisait nuit on avait
fait du feu
[Applaudissements]
moi aussi je faisais partie de la bande
je ne m'inquiète que les kurdes
je la prenais de l'argent parfois mille
deux mille dinars et j'allais acheter du
canard avec
7 faisait quoi de prendre de la drogue
gens prenaient jusqu'à ce que je
m'évanouis ce après je dormais désert
[Musique]
on prenait un sac et ancenis fait comme
ça
et puis on s'endormait
c'était vraiment très fort
non
la banque de l'hôtel méridien
nous avions passé plusieurs jours avec
elle il ya tout juste deux ans
une dizaine de gamins livrés à eux mêmes
autour des grands hôtels du centre-ville
nous on aimerait bien avoir un endroit
où aller
n'importe quel endroit une école un
hôpital n'importe où bon à nulle part où
aller
tous les gens on prend des coups de la
police
[Musique]
les coups des policiers
la drogue et le racket organisé par les
plus grands
à
[Musique]
l'époque arcanes le petit protégé de
chaker à la maison des enfants étaient
en prison pour vol
à
[Musique]
mais nous avions remarqua med le souffre
douleur des grands mais qui réussissent
et malgré tout à éviter de faire des
bêtises 1
je serre les chaussures des étrangers de
raizo terry
me donne de l'argent et à manger
tout ce dont j'ai besoin
[Musique]
med nous l'avons retrouvé à la maison
des enfants
ce n'est pas le premier membre de la
bande de l'hôtel méridien atterrir ici
mais de tous c'est celui qui semble le
plus affecté
depuis qu'il est arrivé il avec l'âme
sans cesse la présence de chaker l'homme
qui l'a sorti de l'enfer
[Musique]
ce matin l'éducateur a réussi à
convaincre à mettre d'assister à son
premier cours mais pour cela chaker a dû
promettre qu'il resterait à ses côtés
dans la place
comme la plupart des autres gamins à
peine ne sait ni lire ni écrire
alors aujourd'hui c'est biologie
illustré pour tout le monde
pourquoi on lui a arraché la moitié du
visage c'est pour voir sa langue
là vous arrivez à voir ses dents est
bien la seule manière de voir sa langue
c'est de lui arracher la moitié du
visage
donc là une partie de ses dents avaient
été arrachées pour qu'on puisse voir sa
langue c'est pareil pour ses yeux et son
cerveau ce premier sourire d'ahmed après
quelques semaines passées ici c'est une
petite victoire pour chaque aire et tous
les autres éducateurs de la maison des
enfants
l'adolescent n'a pas encore les mots
pour s'exprimer mais il revient de loin
il est où le reste de ta bande ils sont
toujours du côté des hôtels maintenant
ils sont du côté du sheraton et toi tu y
es venu quand
qui t'a amené
je suis venu tout seul tout seul
et depuis que tu es là tu n'es jamais
ressorti pas une seule fois n'a pas une
seule fois tu ne veux plus vivre dans la
rue tu n'aime plus la rue
non il ne la supporte plus
non il ne supporte vraiment plus d'être
dehors
[Musique]
dehors ils sont encore nombreux à errer
les anciens compagnons de route d'ahmed
lui-même n'est pas à l'abri d'une
nouvelle rechute à la maison des enfants
un pensionnaire sur cinq s'enfuit au
bout de deux à trois mois
[Musique]
oh